for instance when you beat stone cold
steve austin in the rock right on the
same night
yes how long do you guys have to prepare
these matches of what you're going to do
to each other
how long do you have i mean i know that
a lot of times when it's a
match it's the night of i'm going to do
this to you then you're going to do this
then i'm going to do this
i mean how does how did that happen was
there more preparation did you have to
build up for that
oh you'll love this one so i found out
that i was going to become the
undisputed champion
um by beating
the rock and steve austin's the rock
first steve austin second in the same
night which
first time ever understood enchantment
is a big thing you would think okay you
probably knew about this months ahead
you're planning for it the shows are
written and scripted to to to build
that point uh no not true i found out
about it that afternoon we were in san
diego and i was at catering
and vince mcmahon was there uh with the
undertaker
and they were talking where vince knew i
could hear him but they weren't talking
to me and he said hey take her you know
how you know the business is going down
the toilet
how vince we're putting the title on
jericho
blah and that's how i found out has
become that history
hang on a second hang on he knew you
were listening
yes he did it on purpose he was joking
with you
because that yeah so and and what did
you what was your reaction if you could
remember
the the feeling you had well i mean when
at that point i'd been in the business
for over 10 years so you know how this
business works like
nothing is ever set in stone until you
know it's like being in a movie
if you have a great scene in the movie i
don't know what it's like for you
or you know even tv whatever i'm always
really nervous
when i watch back the scene i just did
the last kevin smith movie json bob
reboot
and we had this wicked scene but she
never know what's he gonna use and
i know he likes to film more than than
necessary just in case
and i'm watching and the scene is great
but when i first saw it i was so
disappointed because a bunch of the cool
stuff got edited out like
i'm always so nervous oh no they edited
that out now right so
it's kind of the same in wrestling you
never know what's going to happen until
it happens and things can change
and so i just took it in stride like my
wife was like why didn't you invite me
you should have told me
i didn't know i didn't know until like
two hours before the show how did you
not know
because that's just how the business is
well how long do you talk to the you
have to go to the rock
and talk to him all right this is what
we're going to do yeah we could put it
together
we had great chemistry so we could put
together a match
half an hour it wouldn't take long and
maybe not even that long like it was
just
some guys are very like now in wrestling
i have another reputation of like
if you have a match with jericho it's
really easy to put together
some guys will sit there for six hours
and put together not me dude
20 minutes we got it we're done
you